[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier secrétaire cher jean
christophe monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs ici ministre aux
militants qu'ils m'avaient accompagné
pendant toutes ces années je voulais
revenir ici rue de solférino après cinq
ans passés à l'elysée non pas parce que
je voulais refaire ce que françois
mitterrand avait lui-même effectué après
être resté quatorze autres à l'elysée il
avait jugé bon et légitime de venir
aussi ici rue de solférino comme pour
adresser également ce qui pour lui était
sans doute son dernier message non je
voulais revenir ici rue de solférino
pour retrouver des souvenirs des visages
car je suis lié à vous comme vous êtes
lié à moi dans notre histoire a été
comme une pendant tout ce temps pour
certains plusieurs décennies et je
voulais aussi revenir ici parce que sans
vous sans le mouvement que vous portez
sans la force que vous incarnez je
n'aurais jamais présidé la france or ce
fut un honneur et une responsabilité que
de diriger la france au nom du peuple
français mais aussi au nom de tous ces
anonymes qui m'ont amené là où je suis
ou là où il y à quelques instants
j'étais je voulais aussi vous dire que
cet honneur de diriger la france
mais venus très tôt dès que j'ai pu
conscience que l'engagement qui était le
mien le militantisme dont je voulais
faire preuve devait conduire notre pays
non seulement à connaître l'alternance
ce qui fut fait
en 1981 mais aussi permettre que la
gauche la gauche celle qui veut diriger
celle qui veut changer transformer le
pays puisse de nouveau accéder aux
responsabilités diriger la france
c'est sans doute pour tout citoyen de
notre pays
une responsabilité qui paraît immense
car notre france est sûrement regardé
partout dans le monde et encore
aujourd'hui comme le pays de la liberté
comme le pays de l'émancipation comme le
pays du progrès et il en sera toujours
ainsi tant que nous continuerons à
porter les valeurs qui sont les nôtres
diriger la france c'est aussi prendre
conscience qu'elle a des devoirs et des
droits mais aussi des responsabilités
partout dans le monde
c'est agir pour le développement
c'est agir pour l'afrique c'est agir
pour la planète pour le climat et c'est
ce que nous avons fait pendant cinq ans
dirigés et présider la france c'est
aussi une lourde responsabilité et que
vous militants dirigeants
vous devez à chaque fois mesurée n'est
jamais facile de diriger un grand pays
comme le nôtre un peuple aussi ardent et
avec des fractures aussi nombreuses et
donc nous devons être exemplaires dans
l'action et solidaire dans le mouvement
et c'est quand il peut y avoir une
défaillance sur ces deux valeurs
essentielles que nous pouvons connaître
des déconvenues mais en revanche quand
nous sommes unis
quand nous sommes conscients de la tâche
qui nous attend notre victoire où notre
combat
à ce moment-là trouve son dénouement et
sa vertu
j'ai eu pendant ces cinq ans à être à la
hauteur de l'histoire de l'histoire qui
m'avait été léguées par nos
prédécesseurs par mes prédécesseurs et
de l'histoire que vous représentez que
nous représentons l'histoire de ce
mouvement qui né au 19e siècle n'a
jamais cessé de penser qu'il était
possible de créer une espérance qui
allait soulever les peuples et
permettent qu'il puisse ordonner le
monde
maîtriser la technologie et faire en
sorte qu'elles puissent être au service
de la justice sociale
c'est ce que vous représentez
aujourd'hui encore j'ai exercé pendant
cinq ans la présidence de la république
dans des épreuves qui ont frappé notre
pays et qui ont profondément bouleversé
les esprits comment aurait-il pu en être
autrement quand il y a eu plusieurs vos
attentes un horrible qui ont saisi de
stupeur notre pays aussi bien au mois de
janvier 2015 que mois de novembre que le
14 juillet 2016 et tant d'autres
assassinats
je pense aux victimes un instant je
parle ses victimes que nous avons
accompagné pour celle qui était encore
vivante ou de leur famille et puis il
fallait dans ces moments-là trouver en
soi en nous la capacité de résister à
tout ce qui pouvait nous fracturé ne
séparait nous diviser et nous empêcher
d'être nous mêmes la france
quelle fierté nous avons eu malgré ses
malheurs de voir tant de dirigeants
venus du monde entier
défilés à 11 janvier à paris sans que
d'ailleurs toutes les conditions de
sécurité n'étaient forcément au point
qu'il aurait fallu mais parce que il
était essentiel qu'il y est
cette force qui puisse se déployer pour
la france et venant du monde entier
c'est veiller aussi à ce que notre pays
puisse tenir bon tenir bon dans ces
circonstances évitez le frac à éviter la
cassure
alors que nous étions déjà blessé ce
sera l'honneur de ma responsabilité que
d'y avoir pas revenue et j'ai toujours
veillé à ce qu'il en soit ainsi
et je suis sûr que le nouveau président
emmanuel macron aura cette même mission
qui est de réconcilier et de rassembler
notre peuple est de veiller à ce que les
forces obscures ne puisse pas jouer les
uns contre les autres
nous avons aussi vécu des crises crise
économique crise européenne crise
monétaire et là encore nous avons tenu
bon
la france est restée la france elle n'a
pas eu besoin de recourir à je ne sais
quel austérité l'europe a résisté et a
même su remonter l'ensemble de ces
crises et le pays est parti l'a fait non
pas pour se protéger de la crise mais
parce qu'il était victime lui même d'une
crise de confiance et nous nous la
france nous avons fait en sorte que
l'europe fasse y compris à la crise des
réfugiés puissent être à la hauteur de
ce que nous considérons comme un droit
imprescriptible qui est le droit d'asile
nous avons fait tout ce que nous
pouvions
et j'en suis fier pour que la grèce
puisse rester dans la zone euro et
chaque fois que je rencontre un division
grecque même un un citoyen grec
il me dit merci me dis pas merci à moi
mais dis merci à vous merci à la france
merci la france quand nous sommes aussi
capables nous l'avons fait jean marc
ayrault est là pour porter secours un
pays ami le mali lorsqu'ils étaient
atteints par cette monstrueuse clitoris
merci merci la france
chaque fois que nous pouvons jouer notre
rôle est signée à paris au lendemain des
épreuves terroristes du 13 novembre un
accord historique sur le climat merci la
france d'être toujours là pour faire
avancer la cause de la planète
oui nous avons cette satisfaction que je
ne veux pas rendre présomptueuse quand
je sais qu'il ya encore tant de malheurs
temps de chômage tant de difficultés
mais permettez moi de vous le dire je
laisse un pays la france dans un état
bien meilleur que celui que j'ai trouvé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne veux pas parler de chiffres
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas forcément le
jour c'est le jour des émotions
partagées des sentiments mêlés et de la
fierté
mais je veux vous dire que chaque fois
que la gauche vient aux responsabilités
du pays
c'est ainsi comme s'il y avait une
fatalité qui pesait sur elle
c'est toujours à elle de redresser les
comptes d'améliorer la compétitivité des
entreprises et de faire en sorte que
notre industrie puisse être chauve et
toujours elle
et je ne connais pas de contre exemples
dans l'histoire
je ne veux pas ici accabler ce qui ne
serait pas de notre famille politique
que je suis aussi ici pour rassembler
encore et toujours mais de ce qui
s'était produit
je ne veux pas remonté à trop loin mais
du front populaire jusqu'à aujourd'hui
c'est toujours la gauche qui a non
seulement fait avancer le progrès social
mais permis qu'il y ait ce redressement
économique et je suis ici dans la cour
pierre bérégovoy tu n'oublies pas car je
l' ai connu je n'oublie pas son geste du
1er mai mais sa fierté au moment où
lui-même était désespérée c'était
d'avoir éradiqué l'inflation dans notre
pays et redresser ses comptes
et tous les socialistes ont toujours se
souvenir que c'est toujours des
socialistes qui ont fait en sorte que le
pays puisse se retrouver espoir alors
même qu'il doutait wissant
des femmes et des hommes de gauche
toujours même ces cinq dernières années
qui ont permis à la retraite d'être
mieux financer d'être lié pour celles
ceux qui avaient travaillé longtemps à
l'espérance de vie à la pénibilité
c'est ce gouvernement c'est gouvernement
jean marc ayrault
manuel valls puis ensuite bernard
cazeneuve qui ont fait que nous
puissions élargit encore l'accès à la
santé la complémentaire tiers payant un
vin je vous accablez de tout ce que nous
avons fait ça prendrait des heures je ne
dis pas cinq ans on met presque cinq ans
et sur l'écologie
nous avons compris comme étant un des
sujets essentiels la loi sur la
transition énergétique
ce que nous avons fait pour la
biodiversité toute cette diversification
des énergies nouvelles
voilà ce que nous avons réalisé et puis
à liberté il n'y a pas de période dans
l'histoire nous avions été associé aux
responsabilités sans qu'il y ait de
progrès de liberté nous ne sommes pas
les seuls à les accomplir sur
l'interruption volontaire de process et
d'autres grâce au combat que nous avions
pu mener qui ont réussi à faire en sorte
que les femmes puissent enfin être libre
eh bien aujourd'hui c'est nous et
l'histoire le retiendra et c'est
irréversible qui avons permis le mariage
pour tous
alors j'étais venu vous dire ces mots
simples je sais ce que je dois à ce que
vous représentez
il n'y a pas de force si elle n'est pas
inscrite dans l'histoire dans un
mouvement qui au fil des générations
donne à chacune et à chacun d'entre nous
un idéal qui lui permet de se dépasser
de s'élever au delà même de sa condition
c'est ce mouvement que vous représentez
c'est cet idéal que vous portez nous
sommes tous des héritiers et en même
temps des passeurs de témoins des
héritiers car nous sommes les légataires
pas universelle mais délégataire de
toutes ces générations qui ont permis
les conquêtes
ces personnages qui nous ont fait rêver
et donnait aussi du courage lorsque nous
doutions et de la fierté lorsque nous
réussissions oui il est toujours
nécessaire de poursuivre ce mouvement
ce mouvement il durera et il donnera
sans doute lieu à des formes nouvelles à
d'autres modes d'organisation à des
structures différentes d'aujourd'hui
mais je ne doute pas que ce que avant
nous des générations ont conçu à travers
ce beau mot de socialisme durera et
perdurera c'est vous c'est à vous
il revient maintenant toutes générations
confondues d'être toujours ce à quoi
vous servez dans la république française
à la justice sociale à l'émancipation
par l'école à la liberté
alors il nous faut toujours penser à
notre utilité
la politique ce n'est pas simplement un
accomplissement personnel jamais la
politique ce n'est pas simplement la
revendication du pouvoir pour lui-même
la politique ce n'est pas un bonheur
celui de décider pour les autres
la politique ce n'est pas simplement une
vie consacrée à la recherche du suffrage
la politique c'est d'être utile utile à
celles et ceux que l'on sait dans la
difficulté mais à tous les français qui
peuvent un moment douté d'elle de la
politique
y a pas pire menace que celle qui
verrait notre pays
douter de la démocratie se diviser comme
il l'a été
hélas dans ce scrutin entre ceux qui se
réfugient dans la peur le repli est ce
qu'ils continuent à vouloir l'ouverture
la démocratie est acceptée le monde
nous devons rassembler réunir tous nos
compatriotes leur donner cette confiance
en eux dans leur destin c'est ça qui
vous attend ne laissez pas des régions
entières et nous l'avons vu ces cartes
et s'éloigner et se dire ils sont ils
seraient ces territoires isolés est
perdu il doit y avoir aucun territoire
de la république
qu'ils soient oubliés abandonnés des
lycées écoles
et quand un de nos compatriotes ou même
un de ceux que nous avons accueilli ici
commence à douter de ce que sont les
valeurs qui nous réunissent de ce qu'est
notre démocratie de ce qu'est d'être
république de ce qu'elle est à l'état
dont ici en france nous devons nous dire
qu'ils assurent la cohésion la
solidarité et l'unité
alors quand nous envoyons un ou une qui
doute
nous devons aller le chercher le prend
de l'emmener le convaincre c'est à cette
tâche que je vous convie
c'est vrai qu'il ya des périodes plus
difficiles que d'autres dans la vie
politique mais faut pas se plaindre des
périodes difficiles quand on est au
pouvoir
la période la plus difficile c'est quand
on est dans l'opposition parce que c'est
le doute qui commence là aussi un sens à
s'installer sur ce que l'on peut faire
moi j'avais connu des périodes
difficiles je parle pas des cinq ans ça
c'était ma responsabilité c'était mon
devoir et je l'avais voulu de ce point
de vue j'ai eu satisfaction faut jamais
plaindre les femmes les hommes qui
exercent le pouvoir
nul n'est venu par la force me chercher
il y a un an pour me conduire à l'elysée
médailles aux jeux je le dis il ya cinq
ans
nul n'est venu non plus me chercher pour
mont pour moins écarté les choses se
font naturellement simplement
placidement donc gelé voulu et c'est un
véritable choix que nous avons fait de
gouverner la france c'est tellement plus
simple de regarder de contester et de
déplorer
voire même de lever l'indignation sans
jamais mettre ses mains dans le moteur
qui permet de faire avancer le pays
simple tellement simple de flatter de
faire croire un monde que l'on pouvait
changer juste parce que on aurait
utilisé le vocabulaire d'autres
continents tellement simple
non il faut prendre la mesure des choses
est toujours difficile de gouverner de
diriger de présider et c'est ce que nous
avons voulu c'est ce que nous avons
décidé et c'est ce qu'il faut continuer
à faire des périodes difficiles j'en ai
connu aussi dans l'opposition quand on
était ramenée à peu et que l'on a repris
la marche la bonne marche la grande
marche la marche longue parce que c'est
un mouvement toujours le mouvement et
c'est bien que il en souhaite ainsi nous
avons fait en sorte que après ces
épreuves du puissions renouveler
redéfinir et repartir il faut toujours
éviter de croire qu'on est emporté par
la vague lorsque l'on était simplement
éclaboussé par les qu il faut tout
simplement pensé qu' il y a une
différence entre les tempêtes que l'on
doit assumer et simplement les flux et
le reflux qui font partie de la vie il
faut croire en la vie au sa capacité il
faut croire aussi aux circonstances de
faut les forcer
et donc je vous appelle vraiment à
inventer à imaginer l'avenir que vous
devez présenter à notre peuple ne pas
vous abandonner à l'incantation à
l'illusion ne pas céder à la confusion
et je vous le dis ici le pays a besoin
de vous et aura toujours besoin de vous
l'enjeu c'est de lutter contre des
fractures les peurs les divisions
sentiment de délaissement des
classements d'isolement d'enfermement
mais l'enjeu c'est surtout de porter un
espoir comme
un destin collectif nous devons croire
en la jeunesse elle a été présente pas
forcément vers ce que nous représentions
il faut aller lui donner les signes que
c'est elle et vairelles moi je n'ai
cessé pendant cinq ans toute ma
présidence de donner priorité à la
jeunesse à l'éducation à l'école de la
république à l'université à la formation
à l'emploi
et c'est vers elle toujours qu'il faut
se tourner toujours il n'ya pas de
possibilité pour une grande idée comme
la vôtre comme la nôtre de faire sans la
jeunesse et encore moins contre la
jeunesse et aussi si je regarde ces cinq
ans jamais nous n'avons eu la jeunesse
contre nous jamais elle ne s'est senti
humilié a baissé au point de se jeter
contre nous aussi bien dans les
quartiers les plus difficiles que dans
les rues de nos villes nous avons évité
ce qui est toujours le plus dur pour un
pouvoir avoir la jeunesse contre elle
alors aller chercher la jeunesse à l'est
la convaincre elle est là elle est
disponible
elles demandent qu'à vous suivre voilà
ce que j'étais venu vous dire chers amis
ces mots simples qui s'appelle la fierté
qui s'appelle la reconnaissance qui
s'appelle l'espérance qui s'appelle la
bienveillance vous devez être des
bienveillant il ya suffisamment de
malveillant je vous l'assuré
[Applaudissements]
une nouvelle page va s'écrire avec un
nouveau président et il faut que vous
vous soyez dans l'esprit de la
construction dans l'esprit de la
responsabilité dans l'esprit de l'unité
de la réussite il faut toujours vouloir
la réussite de son pays
la réussite de ceux qui le dirigent pour
un temps qu'ils laisseront comme
d'autres la place le moment venu il faut
toujours faire le choix de la réussite
de la construction de la république et
de la france et c'est ce que nous avons
fait ensemble et c'est ce que vous ferez
toujours et je vous accompagnerai
partout où vous serez merci
[Applaudissements]